1 on peut composter ensemble voilà et je
m'en occupe et j'assurerai le suivi
technique il n'y aura pas de nuisances
et on va faire du bon terreau ensemble
et cette nouvelle solution séduit une
trentaine de pavillons de quartier
devrait voir le jour prochainement en
vendée voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis vous
pouvez nous retrouver sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
à très bientôt en attendant n'oubliez
pas les meilleurs déchets sont ceux que
l'on ne produit pas ce soir en direct à
18 heures gérard longuet sera l'invité
de preuves par 3 sur public sénat le
président du groupe ump au sénat aura
donc à trois reprises l'occasion de
faire ses preuves
gérard longuet est l'invité de preuves
par 3 ce soir à 18 heures en direct sur
public sénat bonjour à tous suite cet
après-midi du projet de loi sur la
réforme des retraites
les discussions avancent lentement dans
l'hémicycle les sénateurs en sont à
l'article 1er bis
après avoir consacré toute la soirée
d'hier à l'article 1er à et plus de 850
un moment reste à examiner
de son côté ce matin au conseil des
ministres nicolas sarkozy a réaffirmé
que cette réforme était un devoir et
qu'il juge indispensable de la conduire
jusqu'au bout
du côté de la mobilisation sociale elle
continue même si elle est en légère
baisse sont toujours touchés les
raffineries les ports ou encore les
transports et par ailleurs les français
sont toujours appelés à manifester
samedi prochain
tout de suite donc direction l'hémicycle
pour la suite du projet de loi sur la
réforme des retraites puisse pas le dire
puisque la majorité semble que l'umq
n'allonge les débats c'est pas du tout
ça c'est pas du tout ça c'est sûr c'est
sur un dossier aussi important bien
qu'il s'agit d'être précis et nous
réjouissons que cette proposition ait pu
être formulées c'est tout
je mets au voile amendement 77 rectifié
kippour qui compte
il est adopté nous en arrivons 768 il
demeure où il est j'y ai retiré compte
tenu de ce qui s'est passé dans les
demeures dans la misère alors
l'attention du président cet amendement
propose que ce rapport dont qui vient
d'être évoquée fasse l'objet dans le
mois qui suit la publie sa publication
d'un débat public à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat ce qui est un
complément en effet ce rapport censé
faire le point sur le transfert de
cotisations entre régimes intéresse les
parlementaires et plus particulièrement
les représentants des collectivités
locales et territoriales que nous sommes
et qui avons de ce fait à un intérêt
particulier pour le devenir la sienne et
racé m
en effet sur la base ce rapport nous
pourrions par exemple travaillé à
dresser ensemble un bilan des premières
lois de décentralisation que nous avions
dénoncée notamment au regard des
transferts massifs de dépenses publiques
de l'état en direction des collectivités
locales et territoriales des dépenses
dont nous craignons à raison qu'elle ne
soit pas qu'on pense aussi aujourd'hui
si le transfert des personnels de l'état
en direction des collectivités locales
est bien financé force est de constater
que tel n'est pas le cas pour ce qui
relève des cotisations dues au titre des
pensions civiles des fonctionnaires pour
les fonctionnaires en détachement
n'ayant pas opté comme le leur permet la
loi pour l'intégration
pour eux le taux de contribution due par
l'employeur c'est à dire par les
collectivités qui n'était pas
nécessairement demandeuses de transfert
est de 74% alors qu'il n'est que de 27
3% pour les fonctionnaires détachés
ayant opté pour l'intégration
pour faire simple on fait payer aux
collectivités locales qui se sont vus en
quelque sorte imposé le transfert de
certains personnels le même taux de
cotisation qui on applique aux
collectivités qui ont entamé des
démarches volontaires pour accueillir
des fonctionnaires en détachement de la
même manière cela pourrait nous
permettre de poursuivre la réflexion
entamée au sénat avec la proposition de
loi de notre collègue d'hommes et elle
est de suivre réellement l'application
de l'article 9 de la loi du 21 août 2003
portant réforme sur les retraites
qui avait prévu une baisse progressive
du taux de surcompensation qui pèsent
sur les régimes spéciaux jusqu'à
l'extinction prévue théoriquement en
2012 cette question de la
surcompensation est centrale car la
situation actuelle fait peser
d'importantes dépenses sur la cnr acl
ces dépenses si elles ne mettent en
cause à court terme l'equilibre de la
caisse pourrait toutefois la fragiliser
dans l'avenir
particulièrement si l'on s'en tient aux
estimations formulées par le corps des
estimations assise sur un principe
simple la diminution du nombre de
cotisants une diminution que vous
appelez de vos voeux monsieur le
ministre
puisque vous espérez que les
collectivités locales et territoriales
appliqueront la même politique que la
vôtre la non reconduction d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux partant à la
retraite
bref vous aurez compris que nous pouvons
avoir sur le sujet d'importants débats
merci mon cher que le rapporteur
monsieur le président je pense qu'après
les débats d'hier dira qu'il faut
laisser au parlement
l'initiative de ce biais de se saisir du
débat au travers le rapport qui lui est
présenté me sens de bon sens donc avis
défavorable de la commission
une simple réflexion à notre collègue
leucan heureusement que dans le cadre de
la réforme des retraites que vous avez
le tour 2003 aujourd'hui on a une
disparition de la surcompensation sur
dix ans merci mais ma vie pour le
gouvernement
nous allons passer au vote de
l'amendement 768 explications de vote
nicole borvo puis christiane demontès
puis guy fischer s'est pas sur
l'explication de cet amendement c'est je
demandais toujours au rapport je voulais
simplement parce qu'il a fallu que
j'aille recherché évidemment le débat au
journal officiel et donc sur le pacs est
elle je voudrais quand même vous citer
quelques éléments de ce débat d'abord
madame panis rapporteur à l'époque sur
ma ppl sur le pacs
dix ans madame panis ici présente
d'ailleurs eu égard au coût financier à
la complexité que le dispositif de
remercions pour représenter nous sommes
particulièrement attachés à ce que cette
possibilité soit envisagée dans le cadre
plus large du débat sur la réforme des
retraites de 2010
je vous passe la fin de la phrase mais
elle change eur absolument rien monsieur
bockel qui était le représentant du
gouvernement puisqu'il s'agissait d'un
texte qui était étudié par le ministère
de la justice
alors la question monsieur bockel la
question de la pension de reversions
pour le pacsé survivant évoqué par
madame le rapporteur et par plusieurs
orateurs fera sûrement l'objet d'un
traitement particulier lors d'un grand
débat national sur les retraites qui
intéressera tous nos concitoyens
à cette occasion nous pourrons mesurer
les implications concrètes des mesures
proposées
la diversité des situations et envisager
les évolutions que plusieurs d'entre
vous madame muguette dini notamment
appellent de leurs voeux
monsieur gelard de la majorité pour
conclure je le répète nous devons
disposer d'une étude comparative
faisant le point sur la situation à
l'étranger et nous attendons avec
impatience le débat qui aura lieu en
2010 sur les pensions de retraites en
général car ce problème ne peut être
traité à part dont acte c'était le 9
décembre 2010 donc bonjour sur les
engagements de la malle de deux
sénateurs de la majorité et du
gouvernement
la parole est à christiane demontès sur
l'expulsion de votre wii quelques mots
monsieur le président pour vous dire que
nous allons voter l'amendement présenté
par monsieur le cam pour le groupe
communiste parce qu'il nous semble que
c'est un moyen
cet amendement pour que le parlement ne
soit pas déresponsabiliser par rapport à
ces questions là il est extrêmement
important que les rapports et celui là
en particulier puisse faire l'objet d'un
débat au sein de l'assemblée nationale
et au sein du sénat pour alimenter la
réflexion des du législateur donc nous
allons voter cet amendement d'appel et
opposions 10 fichiers non moi je voulais
tout simplement rappelé que l'enjeu du
débat est bien doit tous nous préoccuper
et on sait que dans le problème de la
compensation parce que on dit tout mais
il y à la réalité bon qui s'imposent à
nous par exemple le rapport dit très
bien que en 2007 la compensation
généralisée vieillesse a été financée à
plus de 92% par trois régimes et ça
coûte 2 mais elle nous rappelle toujours
la réalité des chiffres c'est à dire la
cnav pour les 3/5 la cnra c est la
hauteur de 18% et le régime des
fonctionnaires de l'état pour 15%
et puis le complément d'information
aussi qui est intéressant c'est que les
régimes agricoles salariés et
exploitants ont reçu près de 80% des
transferts versés au titre de la
compensation généralisée en 2007
ce sont des réalités banques qui
traduisent bien
le le paysage en fait de la compensation
et je crois qu'il faut pas que l'on
oublie ces chiffres c'est réalité pour
ne pas déborder sur des réalités qui
n'existe pas ou qui de toute évidence
nous conduit sur des chemins où on reste
finalement sur des anathèmes sur des on
dit voilà bien nous allons procéder au
vote de cet amendement 768 qui et pour
qui contre l'amendement n'est pas
adoptée alors en conséquence je me vois
l'article 1er terre qui est pour et qui
est contre
lundi 1er terre est adoptée nous en
arrivons à l'article 2 nathan l'état
isabelle pasquet
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet article
2 nous semble être en totale incohérence
avec l'article premier que nous venons
d'examiner qui porte création d'un
comité de pilotage des régimes de
retraite
nous devons d'ailleurs interrogative
quant au comité de pilotage nous
interrogeons par exemple encore sur la
place que vous entendez donné aux
organisations syndicales et al'inverse
sur celle que vous réservé aux
personnalités qualifiées seront elles
plus nombreuses que les représentants
des organisations syndicales auront
elles le droit de vote
en effet prévoit que le comité de
pilotage sur une ira une fois par an et
pourrait proposer au parlement une
correction au taux de revalorisation des
pensions pour l'année qui suit or en
séance à l'assemblée nationale
vous avez affirmé monsieur le ministre
je vous cite les pensions seront
revalorisées à partir du 1er avril de
façon automatique sur la base de
l'inflation de l'année précédente tel
que calculé par l'insee
mais alors pourquoi substituer la
conférence tripartite par le comité de
pilotage
la réponse à cette question on la trouve
partiellement du moins dans le rapport
de notre collègue et collègue dominique
leclerc qui précise dorénavant la
revalorisation pour l'année sera égal à
la prévision d'inflation établies par la
commission économique de la nation
aussi comment le comité de pilotage
pourrait-il se prononcer sur une
revalorisation éventuelle du montant des
pensions
tout cela donne l'impression que la
revalorisation des pensions ou plutôt
devrais-je dire les éventuelle
revalorisation seront systématiquement
confrontés aux analyses comptables des
analyses limité puisque le comité de
pilotage s'interdit de proposer la
création de ressources nouvelles comme
la taxation des revenus financiers ou la
mise à profit pour les comptes sociaux
des millions de dividendes que se
partagent les actionnaires le passage
devant le comité de pilotage n'est en
fait qu'une mesure esthétique qui sera
sans effet sur le montant des pensions
autrement dit qu'il s'agisse d'une
réunion de la conférence tripartite
nouveau comité de pilotage tout est tout
inscrit dans le marbre des retraités ne
rentre plus droit à la vie
un petit coup de pouce financier la
rigueur est installé et frappera
durement et sans doute même durablement
les retraités de notre pays
enfin je voudrais souligner la pratique
curieuse qui consiste à annoncer la
suppression d'une conférence qui réunit
les représentants de l'état des
organisations syndicales et patronales
au motif
- on pouvait croire c'est par le trou
merci cette méthode nous inquiète et
nous souhaiterions savoir le sort que
vous allez réservé à la confiance des
finances publiques qui ne s'est plus
réuni depuis que vous avez créé la
conférence de la dette publique
une substitution qui n'est pas anodine
puisque si la conférence des finances
publiques
il a pour mission d'étudier toutes les
propositions des organisations
syndicales en matière de financement et
d'utilisation des ressources qui en
découlent notamment en matière sociale
la concurrence de la dette publique elle
est limitée
limité dans sa composition puisqu'elle
intègre par les organisations syndicales
et limité dans ses missions puisqu'elle
se limite à gérer la crise économique
que nous traversons
c'est bien la parole est à ronan
kerdraon
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous abordons l'article 2 qui a
me semble-t-il toute l'apparence d'une
simple dispositions de coordination
cependant il vient à juste titre
conforter les arguments nous avons
présenté hier et par lesquelles nous
demandions la suppression de l'article 1
en raison
rappelez vous de la nature ambiguë de ce
comité d'accompli ont des pouvoirs qu'il
risquait d' instaurer en effet
substituer le comité de pilotage telle
qu'envisagée à la conférence
actuellement compétente pour proposer au
parlement une éventuelle correction du
taux de revalorisation des retraites de
l'année suivante révèle deux
contradictions majeures
nous avons déjà montré la première
contradiction qui est de prétendre
simplifié à tout va et de proposer
parallèlement de charger d'un organisme
supplémentaires un paysage déjà très
largement occupé par le cor l'amex la
cour des comptes la commission des
comptes de la sécurité sociale la
commission de garantie des retraites le
conseil économique et social et la liste
n'est sans doute pas terminée il est
d'ailleurs savoureux
à cet égard de voir comment notre
commission a jugé cette mesure de
substitution je cite une mesure de bon
sens qui permet d'éviter la
multiplication des organismes haddock
excusez du peu au delà c'est le rôle
même de ce comité de pilotage qui enlève
à cette substitution son caractère
anodin
est ce plus encore après les
modifications adoptées par notre
commission qui lui confère émissions d'
alerte dès lors qu'il considérera qu'il
existe un risque sérieux que la
pérennité financière de notre système de
retraites ne soit plus assurée
imagine-t-on compte tenu de cette
mission
compte tenu de l'état de déséquilibre
chronique du régime et compte tenu de ce
que le financement que vous prévoyez et
dont vous n'avez pas voulu débattre dans
ce projet ne permettra pas d'assurer cet
équilibre imagine-t-on un instant que ce
comité proposera lors même qui
constateraient une sous-évaluation des
prévisions de rehausser ce taux c'est
d'ailleurs exactement ce que constate
une commission lorsqu elle souligne que
la conférence ne s'est jamais réunie en
raison et je la cite encore de la
situation financière des régimes de
retraite et du taux de croissance de
l'économie nationale
il est vrai est certes que la correction
prévue par l'article l 161 23,1
peut-être à la hausse mais également à
la baisse il ya nous semble-t-il des
rôles difficilement compatibles et
l'état crainte que ce comité ne se
réunissent pas plus que la conférence
qu'il remplace de plus monsieur le
ministre je m'interroge la réelle
possibilité de mettre en oeuvre cette
disposition au regard des contraintes de
calendrier
une dernière remarque et non des
moindres s'agissant de la rengaine que
vous nous servez en boucle est la seule
que vous ayez pour justifier cette
réforme assurer le paiement des futures
retraites
non seulement les financements que vous
prévoyez sont impropres assurer
l'équilibré du régime
un moyen terme et je ne citerai que vos
hypothèses de croissance que je me
permettrai de qualifié d'irréaliste
unanimement démenti et l'apport de 15
milliards qui ne sont en vérité que du
déficit nouveau mais vous ajoutez encore
une baisse prévisible des niveaux de
retraite à la baisse déjà réalisé par le
changement de leur mode d'indexation
selon les chiffres de la cnav le
basculement d'indexation sur les
salaires à une indexation sur les prix a
déjà représenté une perte de pension de
8% sous la période 94 2003 qui se
poursuit avec une moindre évolution
certes en cumulant les effets paramètres
et revalorisation
puisque l'inflation reste inférieur sur
le moyen et le long terme à
l'augmentation des salaires des
projections du cor lève d'ailleurs
également envisager une dégradation du
taux de remplacement du salaire par la
retraite de 18 à 20 points d'ici 2030
voilà les certitudes que promet cette
réforme un déficit maintenue pour la
cnav
faute d'un projet de financement pérenne
et une nouvelle baisse des pensions de
retraite faute de perspective d'emploi
sérieuses telles et notamment les
expertises averti de la présidente de la
cnav elle même on le voit bien derrière
les discours c'est votre recours à des
stratégies de procédures pour faire
passer à toute force cette réforme
ce que l'on voit c'est votre mépris des
françaises et des français ce que l'on
voit c'est la situation dans laquelle
vos choix dogmatique ont conduit les
finances de ce pays
ce que l'on voit c'est l'augmentation de
la précarité et de la pauvreté
est ce que l'on voit encore c'est votre
incapacité à assumer la responsabilité
de cette situation et que vous proposiez
de confier le pilotage de l' équilibre
financier des retraites
un comité irresponsable est à cet égard
exemplaire sur le ministre se prénomme
ce sénateur vous y mettez tellement de
conviction qu'on a vraiment l'impression
vous croyez pas ce que vous dites et
finalement c'est une bonne nouvelle
parce que mais je voudrais quand même
vous dire que en ce qui concerne la
croissance
vous nous dites âme et aux hypothèses de
croissance est sont pas réalistes et ses
mails et votre action plus importante
vous avez vous avez vous avez vous avez
un projet vous êtes heureux de nous dire
que vous avez un projet j'ai déjà
indiqué d'ailleurs qui reposait sur pas
grand chose mais vous avez un problème
ce projet repose sur des hypothèses
économiques et vous prenez comme il peut
être économique
une hypothèse plus favorable de
croissance de productivité que
l'hypothèse prises par le gouvernement
donc nous dit pas que nos hypothèses de
croissance sont irréalistes alors les
vôtres le sont encore plus la parole est
à bernard cazeau
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre l'article 2 prévoit la
correction du taux de revalorisation des
retraites qui s'est effectuée
préalablement par la conférence
prévoient de le transférer au comité de
pilotage organise de tête
je ne m'attends je ne m'étendrai pas
bien sur cette affaire du comité de
pilotage
puisque mes collègues du groupe
précédemment à n'ont parlé largement en
ce qui me concerne je m'interroge sur le
caractère du mot propositions je
voudrais illustrer mon propos par un
seul exemple en effet à la suite d'une
disposition législative de la réforme
des retraites de 2003 les commissions
des affaires sociales des deux
assemblées avaient l'obligation en 2008
de présenter au gouvernement des
recommandations permettant d'apprécier
les montants de revalorisation des
pensions
plusieurs d'entre elles ces
recommandations ont fait état messieurs
ministre de la nécessité d'améliorer
considérablement les allocations en
faveur des plus modestes
les ministres du travail successifs
s'étaient engagés à le faire
et puis depuis plus rien la hausse de
0,9 virgule 9% en avril 2010 des
pensions du régime général en décalage
complet avec l'évolution du coût de la
vie témoigne de ce dogmatisme avec cet
article ou parachever la primauté des
logiques comptables sur le pouvoir
d'achat des personnes âgées
évidemment on sait d'avancé sur quoi
vont se fonder les conclusions de ce
nouveau comité de pilotage des retraites
pour déterminer à l'avenir le calcul de
la revalorisation des pensions
l'inflation celle ci qui constitue
l'alpha et l'oméga du gouvernement ne
relaie ne reflète pourtant pas le coût
de la vie réelle pour les faibles
revenus
l'impact de ce décalage est bien sûr
particulièrement rude pour les petites
pensions et notamment pour les ruraux
à titre d'exemple les mutuelles santé
ont augmenté leurs tarifs d'environ 5%
cette année et gdf suez a augmenté le
prix du gas 2 9% en avril 9.7 même en
avril dernier santé énergie voilà
monsieur le ministre deux postes de
dépenses contraintes incompressibles qui
pèse proportionnellement plus lourd dans
le budget de retraités modestes
aujourd'hui 4 millions de retraités
perçoivent le minimum contributif
c'est-à-dire 590 1,33 euro et plus de 5
millions d'autres entre 800 et 1100
euros
rien d'étonnant dès lors si la pauvreté
refait surface chez les aînés et le
phénomène risque d'en retirer les
prochaines vagues de retraités subiront
l'impact sur leurs allocations de
carrière davantage touchés par le
chômage et la précarité
le facteur risque ainsi d'être
particulièrement salée si comme le
prévoit le gouvernement
des montants des pensions sont
conditionnés à 1 10 un indice des prix
artificielle remercie ainsi un choc avec
trois amendements discussion commune
identique un amant numéro deux il est
présenté par annie david
merci monsieur le président cette
article 2 modifie donc un article du
code de la sécurité sociale qui fixe des
conditions de revalorisation des
pensions de vieillesse
celles ci sont précisées dans le
troisième alinéa de l'article l 161
tirait 23-1 dudit code qui permet au
gouvernement de proposer au parlement
dans le cadre de l'examen du projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale une correction des taux de robes
revalorisation présenté par une
conférence nationale tripartite
l'article 2 en cohérence avec l'article
premier que nous n'avons pas voté
propose de substituer à cette conférence
le comité de pilotage des retraites le
copilor ses missions qui sont je le
rappelle
veillez au respect des objectifs du
système de retraites par répartition au
maintien d'un niveau de vie satisfaisant
des retraités le rendrait légitime de
votre point de vue pour jouer maintenant
ce rôle de proposition
cet article transfert ainsi au comité de
pilotage
la mission de la commission tripartite
puisque la correction du taux de
revalorisation s'effectuerait désormais
sur sa proposition
il faut toutefois savoir que cette
commission n'a jusqu'à présent jamais
été réunies faute sans doute et nous
pouvons le regretté monsieur le ministre
de volonté politique du gouvernement
je ne vois donc aucunement l'intérêt de
rajouter au comité de pilotage une
mission sinon de dessaisir de ses
prérogatives
une instance de démocratie sociale en
effet le système actuel est tripartite
tandis que la présence de personnalités
qualifiées au sein du comité de pilotage
met en cause les équilibres de la
démocratie sociale qui repose
essentiellement sur la présence des
partenaires sociaux c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous vous proposons par cet
amendement la suppression de cet article
2 merci a maintenant 78 il est présenté
pour le groupe socialiste par jean luc
fichet mais la csu président donc cet
amendement sont 18 nous propose la
suppression de cet article
parce qu'il vise à remplacer la
conférence nationale chargée de proposer
un éventuel correctif au taux de
revalorisation des pensions par le
comité de pilotage des retraites
cet amendement pourrait être un simple
amendement de cohérence
s'appuyant sur l'argumentation que nous
avons développées à propos du comité de
pilotage
en fait il a surtout pour objectif de
faire préciser par le ministre le
processus de décision concernant
notamment la correction du taux de
revalorisation jusqu'à présent et par
dérogation à la loi existante une
conférence présidée par les ministres
chargés de la sécurité sociale de la
fonction publique et du budget et
réunissant les organisations syndicales
et professionnelles représentatives
pouvait proposer au parlement une
correction au taux de revalorisation de
l'année suivante
or dans la rédaction actuelle de
l'article il n'est plus fait état d'une
telle possibilité
et une fois de plus on observe un
glissement qui tend à déconsidérer le
parlement et que deviennent les
partenaires sociaux le rap en temps nous
dit que cette commission ne s'est jamais
réuni posons nous la question pourquoi
c'est donc un certain amendement de
suppression de l'article
mais il a aussi pour objectif de
permettre aux ministres de nous préciser
le processus de décision de l'évolution
du taux d'une année sur l'autre est
aussi de répondre aux questions posées
sur merci merci enchères collègues
amendement 328 rectifier et présenté
pour le groupe rdse par notre collègue
tropéano
merci monsieur le président à l'instar
de l'article l l'article de transfert
comité de pilotage des organismes de
retraite des compétences devant
normalement incomber au gouvernement en
effet le comité aurait la possibilité de
proposer la conviction du taux de
revalorisation de l'année suivante le
présent amendement tend à supprimer
l'article 2 du projet de loi et ce en
cohérence avec notre amendement vise à
la suppression de l'article 1er et du
comité de pilotage des retraites
merci mon cher collègue mission de
rapporter à l'avis de la commission ce
troisième moment
monsieur le président ces trois
amendements dont nous propose la
suppression du comité de pilotage qui
était dans l'article 1
bien évidemment la commission a émis un
avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
président le gouvernement est
défavorable pour les mêmes raisons en
réalité pour dire les choses simplement
on a maintenant un mode de calcul qui
est différent puisqu'il n'est plus basé
simplement sur des prévisions mais sur
un chiffre avérés et en conséquence de
quoi ce que l'on veut c'est justement
laissé aux copies lors la perspective de
pouvoir ajuster si cela n'est nécessaire
le montant de la pension en fonction de
l'indexation sur l'inflation mais s'il
sur la base d'un calcul tête un calcul
avéré donc on voit bien qu'il ya une
modification du mode de calcul on voit
bien en second lieu qu'on peut laisser
aux copies lors la capacité de pouvoir
bouger à la marge qu'il estime utiles et
par définition évidemment on reste
favorable à ce que le copilor existe
voilà donc avis défavorable alors je
veux mettre au point ses trois
amendements identiques qui est pour
qui est contre ben whishaw collègues il
ya doute se désole josé cirque eux on
tient compte des entrées des sorties qui
je peux vous l'assurer sont fort
nombreuses
mais là manifestement ça a trop bouger
alors qu'ils aient pour si vous voulez
bien vous lever oui
qui est contre
on
l'amendement mais pas adopté les trois
amendements éthique ne sont pas adoptées
je mets aux voix je vais me vois
l'article de l'explication de voitures
antiques 2
oui monsieur le président cet article 2
n'apparaîtrait que formel il ouvrirait
la possibilité au comité de pilotage de
décider d'une revalorisation des
pensions alors que dans le même temps on
nous annonce que celle ci demeurera
indexé sur la base de l'inflation
autrement dit cet article de sorek
théorique mais pourtant les retraités
continuent à percevoir des pensions
largement insuffisante et cela va
s'accroître avec le report de l'âge
permettant de bénéficier d'une retraite
sans décote
en effet les salariés les plus usées ce
qui pour pour qui l'âge de la retraite
apparaît comme une délivrance
n'atteindront pas les 67 ans pour partir
à la retraite
preuve en est actuellement plus de 60%
des salariés partent à la retraite à 60
ans quitte à subir des décotes et cela
perdrait déjà beaucoup et ils perdront
encore plus demain c'est à croire mes
chers collègues que vous ignorez les
difficultés que rencontrent les
retraités pour boucler leurs fins de
mois
pourtant dans vos permanence à la mairie
ou au conseil général vous devez les
voire par centaines ces anciens salariés
ces chômeurs pour qui après avoir vécu
toute une vie de précarité se rajoutent
pour certains est de plus en plus
nombreux et bien une vie de misère et
que leur dites-vous désole le contexte
économique la bulle spéculative qui se
recrée explose en permanence nous
conduisent à baisser vos retraites
je n'ose le croire vous ne pouvez
continuer indéfiniment à pressurer
celles et ceux qui ont des
tout donné alors comment voulez vous que
nos concitoyens ne soient pas scandalisé
qu'en entendant vos discours et
s'aperçoivent que de l'autre côté les
hyper riches continuent quant à eux
d'être épargné par votre politique et on
découvre par exemple qu'en mai de cette
année la nomination de lars olofsson à
la tête de la direction de carrefour
s'est accompagnée d'un beau cadeau en
régime de retraite ultra privilégiés
il a fait trois ans seulement chez
carrefour 1 alors que l'ensemble des
salariés sont mis au pain c'est que les
salariés de la grande distribution qui
sont souvent des femmes subissent les
conditions de travail précaires
difficile et des salaires de misère
lars olofsson a de son côté obtenu que
le groupe carrefour lui concède dès la
conclusion de son contrat une retraite à
vie de cinq cent mille euros annuels à
la condition qu'il garde son poste
durant trois années
pour ce faire l'enseigne lui a reconnu
d'emblée 13 ans d'ancienneté
mais le scandale pour nous ne s'arrête
pas là au-delà de ces avantages
retraites
il convient d'ajouter tous les autres
avantages et ils sont nombreux
il bénéficiera par exemple de 130 mille
unités d'actions accordée au titre des
stock options et dont le montant
unitaire est de 33,0 70 le groupe évalue
cette attribution à 1 millions 7,2 euros
carrefour se montrent encore plus
magnanime avec les actions gratuites
165000 et caetera et caetera et je
dirais qu'ils à cela il faut encore
rajouter une allocation de logement égal
à 100 mille euros
et comme cela est de coutume une prime
d'assurance alors tout avantage calculé
or les cinq cent mille euros de retraite
annuelle conférer à vie cette nomination
est bien rapportera au directeur de la
mpt la modique somme de 9,25 millions
d'euros 9 millions dont pratiquement 1
milliard quoi vous voyez d'euros
alors tout cela pour dire quoi et bien
c'est que dans le même temps l'outil que
vous mettez en place et bien il va
servir à quoi il va servir à faire une
pression terrible
prenons bien sûr prétexte de l'évolution
de l'inflation
et bien sûr les salaires et les
retraites
et c'est pour cela que vous avez décidé
pour les trois prochaines années de ne
pas augmenter les salaires des
fonctionnaires vous l'avez décidé et en
même temps eh bien les pensions des
fonctionnaires mais aussi de la cnaf par
exemple la cnav et bien verra ses
pensions augmenter 020 90 % alors c'est
de cette manière là et bien que le
gouvernement fait pression sur les
salaires et les retraites
et cela dans tous les pays de l'union
européenne
nous constatons les mêmes principes
c'est à dire faire pression ce qui
permet de vivre quotidiennement et cela
touche bien entendu le plus grand nombre
je mets aux voix l'article 2 qui est
pour
tu es qui contre mes chers collègues et
un groupe qui n'a pas voté il ya donc
doute et donc je fais je vais demander
de procéder par assis debout qui sur
l'article 2 pieds pour recevoir
un chose est sûre que si je vous assure
que si qui comprend
bien visible
l'article 2 est adopté
alors nous aimerions un article 3
l'apport l'état isabelle laraque parfois
non la parole est à isabelle pasquet les
balles à la parole et à guy fischer et
fischer
voilà vous allez me dire
merci président l'article 3 de ce projet
de loi a pour objet de renforcer
l'information dispensée aux assurés qui
avait été mise en place par la loi du 21
août 2003 il vise alors fournir une
information générale sur le système de
retraite dès leur première acquisition
de droits à la retraite et à créer un
entretien personnalisé pour tout assuré
à partir de l'âge de 45 ans comme vous
le savez la loi du 21 août 2003 a
instauré le droit à l'information
individuelle des assurés sur leur future
retraite et vous le savez aussi ce
système a pris un certain temps pour se
mettre en place et il apparaît encore
inégale selon les régimes et selon les
régions
c'est l'actuel l'article l100 61-17 du
code de la sécurité sociale qui contient
les modalités de ce droit à
l'information est cet article que vous
entendez modifié alors concernant le
fond de cet article nous pouvons résumer
notre position par ces mots oui à
l'information des assurés mais non à la
propagande en faveur de la retraite par
capitalisation et a un rôle de conseil
en placement ou au mélange des genres
alors nous disons oui à l'information
car nous sommes pour le fait que les
assurés soit informé plus tôt et mieux
sur les droits qu'ils acquièrent en
matière de retraite nous ne pouvons pas
être content ce qui améliore un droit
pour tous nos concitoyens et
concitoyennes
une fois cette position de principe
énoncé il faut regarder de plus près ce
que cet article 3 prévoit est aussi ce
qu il ne prévoit pas laissant ainsi les
coudées franches au gouvernement de
préciser le dispositif par décret et
comme vous allez le voir l'article 3
permet beaucoup de choses
et là les choses dérapent dans ce qui
est déjà prévu
elle nous inquiète encore plus à la
lecture du rapport sur le texte qui
soulève autant de questions qu'il
n'apporte de réponses le renforcement du
droit à l'information proposée
le texte se divise en plusieurs aspects
le premier nous semble acceptable
l'assuré va bénéficier d'une information
générale sur le système de retraite par
répartition et va être informés des
règles d'acquisition des droits à
pension
le contenu exact de cette mesure sera
fixé par décret mais on peut espérer
monsieur le ministre qu'il s'agira d'une
information neutre et de n'orienter le
second aspect constitue une nouveauté
il est prévu que les assurés
bénéficieront d'un point d'étape
retraite à leur demande et à 1h fixé par
décret
et à partir d'ici comme vous allez le
voir le texte de l'article 3 permet à
notre sens des dérives qui nous inquiète
en premier lieu le rapport n'est pas en
mesure de dire si ce point d'étape se
fera de visu ou par téléphone
on nous dit qu'un véritable entretien
coûterait plus d'argent que simple
entretien téléphonique
cela semble vrai mais il faut savoir ce
que l'on veut
soit on met en place ce point d'étape
soit on ne le met pas même mais si on
prévoit elle doit être véritable et bien
sûr cela a un coût 730 équivalents temps
plein mais on voit les limites de tout
ce qui se fait par téléphone
on peut craindre qu'un une simple
consultation par téléphone ne
suffiraient pas et si on veut informer
véritablement les assurés il faut les
recevoir comme on ne veut pas se donner
les moyens de faire un véritable
entretien
on nous dit qu'une solution alternative
consisterait à s'appuyer sur les
employeurs pour réaliser cet entretien
individuel
là on franchit une étape qui nous paraît
très dangereuse nous pensons que cette
solution serait très mauvaise car elle
constituerait un grave mélange des gens
ce n'est pas à un employeur de parler de
cela à son employé
ce n'est pas son rôle en encart un
mélange des gens de plus l'employeur
n'est pas compétent pour cela une pme
n'a rien à voir avec une grande
entreprise leur capacité à remplir cette
mission sont radicalement différentes
cette solution nous semble à proscrire
mais ce n'est pas tout l'article 3
contient dans sa rédaction même les
conditions d'un détournement de l'objet
de cet entretien d'une information il
pourrait devenir l'occasion d'un fort
est systématique encouragement à
souscrire des produits financiers pour
se constituer soi-même sa retraite par
capitalisation et nous allons revenir
sur ce point dans un instant merci merci
la parole est à claude domeizel merci
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues la loi
d'août 2003 dans son article 10 acres et
le droit à l'information ce qui a généré
la création d'un groupement d'intérêt
public connu sous le nom de gip info
retraite
ce gip info retraite à lui un travail
titanesque a réalisé dès son
installation puisqu'il a dû créer un
annuaire regroupant tous les assurés
sociaux et un collecteur permettant à
partir de cet annuaire d'aller collecter
toutes les informations dans tous les
régimes de base et dorothée et est
complémentaire
c'est à dire de 35 régimes aujourd'hui
et à partir de 2011 les toutes les
cohortes seront servis c'est à dire de
35 à 45 ans les assurés sociaux
reçoivent un imprime une série
d'imprimer qui s'appelle le relevé
individuel de situation dans lequel
jamais eu ici dans lequel on on mais on
donne la situation de au regard de la
retraite de tous les assurés sociaux je
dis bien de tous les assurés sociaux et
à partir de 50 ans ont fourni le gip
info retraite fourni ce qu'on appelle
une estimation individuel globale et ça
répond à la question quel sera votre
retraite
si vous partez à 61 ans à 60 ans 62 et
c'est thomas dit
a déjà un effort ça n'est pas parfait
mais actuellement on peut dire que 98 %
des assurés sociaux perçoivent ce
document qu en dit long de 35 40 45 ans
et cetera ils le perçoivent et le taux
de satisfaction est remarquablement bon
et enfin le taux d'erreur est très
faible puisqu'il y est environ de 2 ou 3
%
le fait qu'il y ait des erreurs qu'ils
puissent être relevé eh bien ça permet
de rectifier ne pas se trouver avec des
erreurs au moment de la liquidation de
la retraite alors ce qui est proposé ce
qui proposait dans cet article 3
et bien moi je me pose des questions
parce qu'il fait doublon avec ce qui
existe aujourd'hui je le crains quand on
dit informations des nouveaux assurés
je vous signale que le gip info retraite
envoie un document que j'ai ici et qui
dans lequel on donne toutes les
indications sur la retraite et qui
expliquent par un schéma quels sont les
divers régimes de base et
complémentaires
cet article 3 propose le relevé de
situation individuelle électronique
bah écoutez cet article 3 pour cette
partie va un peu de vent de la victoire
au secours de la victoire parce que
c'est fait c'est fait le relevé
individuel de situation est électronique
et expérimentale aujourd'hui et va
devenir effective pour tout le monde
à partir du mois de juin enfin sur cet
entretien individuel
j'ai rencontré monsieur le ministre en
tant que comme vous l'avez compris le
responsable du gip info retraite et
monsieur le ministre j'ai eu l'occasion
de vous faire part de mes interrogations
sur cet entretien à 45 ans qui fait
vraiment doublon avec ce qui existe ça
pose des questions sera un entretien en
face à face qui va être très coûteux des
guerres
est-ce que ça ira jusqu'au conseil parce
que la limite entre l'entretien et le
conseil est tout de même ténue et ça
peut engager le celui qui donneraient
éventuellement ce conseil et sia conseil
ça signifie qu'il faudra a confirmé par
écrit parce que ça me paraît tout à fait
normal que une information que vous
recevez vous en demande y est la
confirmation par écrit at on m'a dit il
ya beaucoup d'interrogations et monsieur
le ministre je vous avais suggéré en
tant que responsable du gip info
retraite
je vous avais suggéré particulièrement
pour le l'entretien 45 ans que vous
fassiez un peu le point en y instaurant
à titre expérimental je sais pas
géographiquement ou autre mais pour voir
ce que ça pourrait rendre est donné en
réalité en grandeur nature
je jour d'hui cet article 3 même si les
généreux même s'il propose une réforme
importante enfin importante
il y en a une en matière de droits une
formation est bien ou bien elle propose
des aménagements qui existent déjà ou
bien elle le pose beaucoup de questions
en matière de coûts et en matière de de
renseignement qui puisse être donnée
c'est la raison pour laquelle notre
groupe sera très on aura des amendements
mais sur ce sera très réticent à cette
adresse et a7 cet article 3 merci
claire-lise campion chers collègues cet
article iii vise à renforcer
l'information qui a dispensé aux assurés
en matière de retraite et complète le
droit de chaque assuré d'obtenir un
relevé de situation individuelle la
recherche de l'amélioration de
l'information c'est évidemment consensus
elle répond à une demande forte des
assurés eux même perplexe est souvent
démuni devant la complexité de
l'organisation en général de notre
système de retraite
une information générale dans un délai
de deux ans suivant l'année en cours
duquel la validation du premier
trimestre d'assurance est effectué et
donc plutôt positive
en effet en raison d'une flexibilité du
travail toujours plus accrue nombre de
salariés sont et seront amenés à
connaître au cours de leur carrière
différents secteurs professionnels
différents emplois il est donc
nécessaire de les sensibiliser à leurs
droits et aux conséquences de certains
des choix qu'il pourrait être amené à
faire
je pense notamment au temps partiel qui
n'affecte pas la durée d'assurance dans
le régime général
lorsque l'activité d'exercer au moins à
mi-temps mais qui a des conséquences
sensibles sur le salaire de référence
sur la base duquel sera calculée la
future pension
notre législation prévoit la possibilité
de surcotiser par exemple je ne vais pas
m'attarder ici dans une critique de ce
système mais nous y reviendrons plus
tard
mais je veux tout de même dire qu'il est
regrettable que les salariés ne soient
pas informés d'un minimum de règles qui
s'y attachent par ailleurs l'article 3
prévoit un entretien à la demande des
assurés à 45 ans entretien au cours
duquel les simulations du montant
potentiel de leur future pension leur
seront communiquées nous comprenons le
souci du rapporteur de notre commission
de mieux informer les assurés mais
pouvons nous réellement nous fier aux
simulations du montant potentiel de la
future pension simulations réalisées à
législation constante et sur la base
d'hypothèses économique
pouvons nous réellement évaluer le
niveau de la pension va t'en à l'avance
et je m'interroge sur l'efficience d'une
telle simulation vu des nombreux aléas
qui peuvent surgir au cours des vingt
années suivantes la pouvoir anticiper le
montant de sa future pension est un
élément déterminant de la confiance dans
le système de retraite
en effet mais permettez nous de douter
de la fiabilité de telles évaluations la
possibilité d'un entretien à chaque
tournant de la carrière professionnelle
nous semble me semble beaucoup plus
profitable aux salariés qui pourra
effectuer un choix éclairé
et d'ailleurs cette proposition fait
l'objet d'un de nos amendements que nous
vous présenterons monsieur colonie de
vide
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre cela vient d'être rappelé cet
article 3 complètent donc le dispositif
de l'article l100 61-17 du code de la
sécurité sociale qui prévoit pour chaque
assuré le droit de connaître le relevé
de sa situation individuelle face à la
retraite il ajoute ainsi une information
générale sur le système de retraite
français après deux semestres de
validation et mentionne la possibilité
pour chaque assuré de 45 ans ou plus de
bénéficier d'un entretien individuel sur
les droits constitués ainsi que d'une
simulation du montant de sa future
pension
ces dispositions visent donc à améliorer
l'information des assurés sur les
dispositifs de retraite et sur leur
situation personnelle ce qui
convenons-en est plutôt positif cet
article ne serait donc pas si problème
problématique s'il était présenté seul
mais malheureusement il ne peut être
détachés de l'arsenal de mesures
destructrices des droits sociaux des
salariés que comporte ce projet de loi
en effet cet article s'inscrit dans une
logique globale néfaste pour chaque
assuré informer et communiquer serait
bénéfique
seulement 6e de mission constituer le
pendant d'une réforme juste et équitable
les entretiens individuels et
l'information générale que l'article
prévoit ne sont utiles que dans la
mesure où elles sont effectuées pour les
salariés j'entends par là en leur faveur
car ce n'est pas tout d'informer encore
faudrait-il que l'on se penche sur le
contenu de cette information car
l'information est malheureusement
rarement neutre et peu trop souvent se
transformer en outil de communication et
de propagande gouvernementale ainsi
l'information sera logiquement effectué
dans le sens de la réforme du
gouvernement
qui sous ses airs de réaffirmer
l'attachement au régime de retraite par
répartition fait la fin la part belle
aux retraites par capitalisation
qu'est ce qui peut donc nous garantir
dès lors que chaque assuré ne recevra
pas une information l'incitant à
souscrire à ce type de retraite
rien ne nous l'assurent bien au
contraire nous avons toutes les craintes
de voir ce schéma se réaliser car
l'objectif de cette réforme réside ni
plus ni moins en la liquidation de notre
système de retraite par répartition
fondé sur la solidarité
intergénérationnelle
ce projet de loi est en effet la
véritable incarnation d désir de
domination capitaliste
je voudrais ici évoquer l'économiste
frédéric lordon et son récent ouvrage
intitulé capitalisme désir et servitude
l'auteur présente un modèle théorique
qui s'applique parfaitement aux
retraites dans les sociétés capitalistes
s'affrontent deux désirs contradictoires
ce de l'entreprise et ceux des salariés
chacun a des aspirations différentes qui
lui sont propres et qui sont
inconciliables
l'employeur tend à considérer l'individu
comme une source de production et à le
rendre corvéables à merci pour un coût
minimal favorisant les gains de
l'entreprise le travailleur lui ton sens
inverse à protéger sa sphère d'existence
en dehors du travail a augmenté son
niveau de vie
l'individu à aspire donc à ce que sa
situation soit la plus éloignée possible
des désirs du patronat tandis que
l'employeur souhaite au contraire faire
en sorte que les désirs de l'employé
rejoignent parfaitement ce de
l'entreprise
je vous le rappelle c'est un ouvrage qui
dit ça capitalisme désir et servitude
mais je partage complètement cette
analyse c'est dans ce rapport de force
que la loi prend tout son sens pourtant
sedan cette réforme des retraites le
gouvernement agit au nom unique des
entreprises
le texte contribue ainsi à réduire les
écarts entre les deux volontés au seul
avantage au seul avantage des
entreprises en imputant le poids du
financement des retraites à 85% aux
salariés tandis que seuls deux maigres
et symbolique prélèvements sont prévues
sur les revenus du capital et
et aux revenus n'ayant pas réussi à
annuler les aspirations à
l'épanouissement en dehors du travail de
nos concitoyens le gouvernement
entreprend dès lors de passer cette
réforme en force
méprisant les grandement populaire qui
se font entendre chaque jour davantage
cette réforme épouse purement et
simplement les intérêts du capital
répond aux exigences du medef et tend à
satisfaire les attentes des agences de
notation au mépris de celle des
travailleurs alors je le réaffirme je
suis plus que sceptique quant à la prise
en compte des intérêts des as tu des
assurés dans l'information générale et
personnel que prévoit cet article car si
la réforme ne s'intéressent guère aux
assurés on ne voit guère pourquoi
l'information le ferait pour nous la
seule réforme des retraites valable et
la seule information adaptée sont celles
qui bénéficient aux assurés qui accorde
toute sa place au régime de retraite par
répartition
merci la parole et héros de pirates
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet article
institue une amélioration du droit à
l'information des assurés sociaux sur
les différents régimes de retraite ce
qui est nous encore dans tous une bonne
chose ce droit est institué par la loi
de 2003 et prévoit la fourniture tous
les cinq ans d'un relevé de situation
individuelle et à ses 55 ans d'une
estimation indicative globale du montant
de la pension et à partir de là 45 ans
et à partir de 55 ans cette mission et
jusque là assurée par le gip info
retraite
toutefois il n'y a aucune raison de se
réjouir car malgré tout cette
disposition relève en filigrane les
grands manques de votre texte en effet
de plus en plus contraints à une grande
mobilité géographique et professionnelle
les retraités dépendent souvent de
plusieurs régimes 42% d'entre eux
dépendent de deux régimes 31% de 3 15%
de 4 ce qui démontre la nécessité de
régler le problème du calcul de la
pension des polypensionnés ce problème
est immédiatement suivie par la question
des femmes des carrières des femmes
soumis bien évidemment comme le souligne
pudiquement les termes de l'alena
à 4 aux choix et aux aléas de carrière
éventuelles pour ma part je préfère
parler de carrières morcelées avec peu
de perspectives d'évolution aux horaires
décalés aux temps partiels imposés aux
salaires sous-évalué voilà la réalité
professionnelle des femmes ainsi que les
éléments de réponses pourront apporter
le préposé à l'information à tous ses
salariés qui ont cumulé tout au long de
leur carrière professionnelle des petits
contrats sans arriver à décrocher un
contrat durable
que dire aussi à ces femmes qui
travaillent depuis des années - da mi
temps ou à temps partiel sans réel
impact positif sur leur fiche de paye et
sans pouvoir de fait de faire valider
leurs trimestres
j'imagine aussi le désarroi de tous ceux
et toutes celles qui au delà de 45 ou 50
ans ne trouve plus d'emplois stables
bref quelle réponse pour apporter
concrètement le préposé à l'information
à nos concitoyens soumis aux aléas de la
vie économique et sociale et rejetés aux
marges du système de l'emploi durable et
de la protection sociale la réponse
envisagée à toutes ces questions et
selon votre texte à l'alinéa 5
d'une part une simulation de leur niveau
de pension et d'autre part à l'alinéa 4
une information sur les dispositifs leur
permettant d'améliorer le montant de
leur future pension de retraite ce
dernier point je le crains la porte
ouverte à la mise en place de la
capitalisation des points retraite et
j'imagine déjà la scène où le vaillant
préposé rétorquera à l'assuré désolé je
ne peux rien faire d'autre pour vous
mais si vous souhaitez augmenter votre
future pension mettez de l'argent de
côté
je n'ai rien de mieux à vous proposer
autrement dit après avoir subi
l'écrasement des puissances économiques
et la précarité salariale
votre réforme ne fera qu'accroître la
pauvreté et l'incertitude pour toutes
ces personnes qui n'ont pas eu la chance
d'accéder à l'emploi
mais pour cela il faudra et faudrait une
politique de l'emploi
à contre courant de celles que vous
menez au service de l'accroissement des
profits des entreprises
une réelle information d assurer aurait
été d'autant plus judicieux si votre
réforme ambitionner la lutte contre la
précarité salariés
al mais vous ne cessez de protéger les
revenus du capital malgré les récentes
déclarations du ministre du budget sur
le bouclier fiscal poudre aux yeux au
lendemain d'une forte mobilisation alors
que vous ignorez le bouclier social dont
notre société a tant besoin
car la seule information que les
salariés notre pays auront à leur
disposition et celle de la baisse de
leur niveau de pension un nivellement
par le bas
ascenseur vers toujours plus de
précarité pour des millions de chômeurs
et de salariés à temps partiel dont le
nombre ne cesse d'augmenter
cet article propose certes une
amélioration de l'information mais il
nous semble indispensable d'aller plus
loin
merci ben l'immobilier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
l'article 3 suscite chez nous une
crainte l'utilisation du point d'étape
retraite non pour simplement informer
les assurés mais pour promouvoir la
souscription de produits financiers et
donc la retraite par capitalisation
en effet selon l'exposé des motifs il
est prévu que cet entretien portera
notamment je cite sur les avantages
respectifs des différents dispositifs
d'incitation à la prolongation
d'activité ainsi que sur les dispositifs
leur permettant d'améliorer le montant
de leur future retraite
nous y voilà le point étape retraite à
45 ans risque de se transformer en une
information orienté et une incitation
systématique à recourir au plan
d'épargne-retraite cet entretien
pourrait devenir l'occasion d'une
réclame pour les retraites par
capitalisation
le glissement est si facile et si tu
entends nous sommes catégoriquement
contre cette instrumentalisation de ce
droit à l'information
cet entretien ne doit pas servir à
orienter la population vers la retraite
par capitalisation
sous couvert de les informer comme le
font si publicité déguisée en de faux
spot informationnel nous sommes là dans
le mélange des genres comme le souligne
le rapport cela pose de nombreux
problèmes quant à la nature même de
l'entretien informations conseils
information vente de produits financiers
si l'entretien donné lieu à des conseils
en matière de choix de carrière de
possibilités de surcotisation de
souscription de produits d'épargné
retraite etc les services informe en
changera de mission en faisant du
conseil en finance ce qui pourrait
engager leur responsabilité et non plus
de la simple information mélange des
genres encore donc entre le public et le
privé
mais cela semble devenir une habitude
ici et pourquoi pas ensuite confié cette
mission d'information à de grandes
entreprises d'assurances ou de banque
évidemment je j'imagine vos intentions
sont connus de tous
livrer l'ensemble du système de
retraites au privé à de grandes sociétés
qui n'attendent que cela
et qui savent qu'elles peuvent compter
sur vous nous avons donc de grandes
réserves sur cet article 3 qui peut
constituer un vrai cheval de troie pour
la retraite par répartition contre la
retraite par répartition pardon et les
risques sont réels car encore une fois
le contenu de cette étape sera déterminé
par décret est donc laissée à la libre
appréciation du gouvernement enfin une
petite remarque le conseil
d'administration du gip et info retraite
a pris la décision de ne pas envoyer
cette année d'estimation individuel
globale aux assurés de la génération 55
ans motive que le présent projet de loi
va modifier un certain nombre de
paramètres de calcul des pensions de
retraite
soulignons meschers connexes que l'on
peut qualifier d'une étrange
anticipation la manière d'agir du
gouvernement est ici du conseil
d'administration du gip et info retraite
nous choque
il considère comme acquises l'adoption
de ce projet de loi alors qu'il n'a pas
encore été voté c'est une nouvelle
manière de considérer que le travail
parlementaire n'a que très peu d'effet
sur les textes qui sortent tout droit du
sommet de l'état j'en ai vu ça
mais monsieur le président je vais
intervenir sur l'article que j'avais
prévu d'intervenir sur l'amendement
numéro 2 153 et je me suis aperçu en
lisant mon amendement que l'article 300
mon amendement m ou beaucoup moins
intéressant donc je me permets
d'intervenir en apportant un élément
intéressant à l'article 3 qui est
l'amendement que j'aurais le droit de
présenter si l'article 40 n'avait pas
été utilisé en plaine en pleine séance
de façon à comprise est un peu brutal
cet amendement demandé que les assurés
pis dans l'article aujourd'hui on dit
les assurés bénéficient à leur demande à
partir de 45 ans et dans les conditions
fixées par décret donc cet amendement
supprime et à leur demande
car cet amendement vise à fournir une
meilleure information aux assurés
sociaux sur leurs droits à la retraite
nous avons déjà évoqué l'opacité de
notre système de retraite
avec sa trentaine de régimes différents
des complications pour les
polypensionnés et caetera et caetera et
c'est sans parler d'un logiciel de la
législation qui évolue régulièrement de
sorte à ce que la règle du jeu changent
régulièrement et qu'au final les assurés
sont dans le flou le plus complet
concernant leur situation
c'est pourquoi il est essentiel de mieux
informer chacune et chacun sur ses
droits à la retraite
il est important de bien préparer sa
retraite et de connaître des
conséquences de tel ou tel choix
professionnel sur sa future pension se
pensant cependant nous pensons que les
entretiens prévus par l'article 3
doivent être rendues obligatoires afin
que l'information circule réellement si
l'entretien se fait sur demande
il n'est pas certain que les assurés
sociaux et connaissances de la
possibilité même de bénéficier de cet
entretien
et on en reviendra donc au problème de
départ une trop faible informations sur
les sur les droits à la retraite
c'est pourquoi j'invite est arrêtée cet
amendement afin de s'assurer que tous
les assauts
que tous les assurés sociaux bénéficient
du même niveau d'information concernant
le droit à la retraite
alors je suis vraiment étonné de
l'utilisation de l'article 40 pour cet
amendement franchement on ne peut plus
rien demandé on ne peut plus demander un
droit à l'information
d'ailleurs il as jamais été précisé que
c'était l'état en tant que tel qui avait
à payer que se faisait des dépenses
supplémentaires donc jusqu'où va
l'article 40 et je voudrais qu'on mette
un article maintenant que nous on
utilise l'article 40 c c'est à dire
qu'on ne on donne le droit ou non de
déposer un amendement ici qui serait
contre les intérêts des citoyens
c'est à dire qu'on puisse dire voilà ça
c'est un amendement qui va encore faire
payer les plus pauvres donc on devrait
avoir un droit de veto ici est de dire
nous on refuse que vous fassiez payer
davantage les citoyens parce que en
l'occurrence lorsqu'il s'agit mais non
mais bien sûr que métal
alors ces carences à on devrait quand
même avoir le droit de protéger les
humains on devrait d'abord avoir le
droit de protéger et les enfants qui
travaillent dans certains pays et
garantir les droits sociaux des hommes
et des femmes de ce paix dans ce pays
1 en l'occurrence l'as que c'est à leur
demande ils sont obligés de faire une
démarche et vous savez très bien que
l'administration française
monsieur le ministre marche parfaitement
que dès qu'on téléphone une attitude une
réponse que la sq on tombe sur une
plateforme téléphonique suivant les
moments on attend plus ou moins
longtemps donc en fin de compte si ce
n'est pas fait de façon systématique et
celui qui va le demander ce sont des
coûts supplémentaires pour lui donc à
partir du moment où l'organisme pas on
demande à l'administration
on est obligé de s'adresser à
l'administration et comme
l'administration ce n'est pas
obligatoire va dire ah là là un mauvais
coucheur encore quelqu'un qui va nous
poser des tas de questions
et comme on n'a pas pris l'habitude de
dialoguer de certaines façons eh bien on
va laisser effectivement la personne
poser des questions posées les questions
pour à la fin lui dire mon peux pas
répondre à toutes les demandes que vous
faites vous comprenez vous nous demandez
bien d'autres choses et comme on n'a pas
pris l'habitude de prévoir la réponse
est bien ça veut dire que c'est un
traitement informatique nouveau qui vous
met en place et qui va demander beaucoup
de travail à la fois celui qui demande
et à celui qui devra répondre
il est quand même plus simple de mettre
une réponse systématique
c'est pourquoi je vous proposais cet
amendement que je trouvais intéressant
de bon sens et je ne comprends pas
absolument pas la censure des
administrateurs du sénat de la
commission des finances
et oui et oui et oui ils sont servis
c'est effectivement de qui c'est une
question et glace qu'on m'a dit qu'il
travaillait beaucoup
je leur demande de se reposer et de
faire moins de 100 sur neuf amendements
discussion commune l'amendement 973 il
est présenté par
il est défendue non françois autain
je suis à l'explication amendement 973
aussi reconnue et oui alors l'article 3
de ce projet de loi vise à renforcer
l'information dispensée aux assurés en
matière de retraite d'une part en
prévoyant de leur fournir une
information générale sur le système de
retraite dès leur première acquisition
de droits à la retraite
les sénatrices et sénateurs du groupe
crc spg ne peuvent naturellement pas
être opposés à une disposition qui tend
informé des assurés sociaux de leurs
droits en matière de retraite s'ils
tentaient que cette information soit
complète
exact et ne concerne que les régimes
obligatoires de base
si je dis cela c'est que nous avons
suivi les tentatives de près les
tentatives de certains sénateurs
appartenant tous à la majorité
sénatoriale et qu'ils entendaient
profiter de ce support pour promouvoir
le cumul emploi retraite ou tout
bonnement les mécanismes de retraite par
capitalisation
il faut dire que les enjeux financiers
sont colossaux et que les banques et les
entreprises voudraient s'approprier ce
mode de financement
notre amendement 973 s'inscrit donc vous
l'aurez compris dans un contexte
d'information de nos concitoyens s'ils
sont demandeurs des dispositifs mis en
place depuis 2003 c'est que tout d'abord
il recherche dans le tôt dans leur
carrière professionnelle tous les
éléments leur permettant de justifier
d'une retraite à taux plein le plus vite
possible
nul doute que le passage de 60 à 62 ans
et de 65 à 67 ans réduira
considérablement les ardeurs de celles
et ceux qui tentent de reconstituer
l'intégralité de leur parcours
professionnel
mais s'ils sont autant demandeurs c'est
que d'une certaine manière ils ont peur
votre politique de réduction
systématique des droits
la généralisation des périodes de
précarité la suppression des majorations
de durée d'assurance ou des
bonifications est anxiogène
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons que cette information soit
adressée dès la première année de
cotisation des salariés sans attendre
qu'ils aient atteint une durée minimum
d'assurance une information la plus
rapide possible sur les droits actuels
sur la législation en vigueur ou encore
les incidences éventuelles de ce qu'il
est convenu d'appeler les accidents de
la vie professionnelle
tout cela contribue à redonner de la
confiance envers notre régime de
retraite et la répartition
pour toutes ces raisons nous vous
invitons à voter en faveur de cet
amendement
normalement 972 gérard le cam sur le
président ce mini chers collègues oui
cet amendement et l'amendement de repli
du précédent nous avons en effet
préjuger du fait que vous refuseriez
sans doute l'adoption de notre
amendement 973 qui prévoyait notamment
que les assurés sociaux étaient informés
dès la première année de cotisation sans
qu'il n'y ait lieu d'attendre une durée
manie minimum d'assurance
il s'agissait pour nous de permettre aux
salariés de recevoir au plus vite un
hindou semant un move tromper relatifs à
sa situation
un document bardot relatifs à sa
situation en termes de droits à la
retraite notamment afin de le rassurer
sur le fait que bien de bien que de
jeunes et primes aux cotisants il
bénéficiait d'une prise en charge par
les régimes obligatoires de base
cet amendement pour sa part s'inscrivant
dans cette logique mais n'entendant plus
apporter de modifications aux
dispositions relatives à la durée de
cotisation se limite à proposer comme le
texte issu de l'assemblée nationale que
l'assuré bénéficie d'une information
dans l'année qui suit sa première
cotisation
merci un moment 1193 sud rapporteur
monsieur le président qui nous a semblé
préférable au sein donc de la commission
que l'on puisse donner cette première
information dès que les deux premiers
trimestres validés et bien soit
consécutif mais aussi un moment 305
dunning yannick bodin mais le président
monsieur le ministre
chers collègues cet amendement concerne
nos compatriotes établis à l'étranger
il propose en effet d'inclure
expressément les assurés sociaux établis
hors de france dans le dispositif
consistant à dispenser une information
sur la retraite
les assurés résidant à l'étranger
doivent en effet pouvoir solliciter
auprès de leur caisse de retraite un
entretien sur les droits qui leurs sont
constituées dans les régimes de retraite
légalement obligatoire et sur les
perspectives d'évolution de ces droits
cet entretien qui auraient lieu à partir
de 40 50 puis tous les cinq ans pourrait
être par exemple téléphonique
compte tenu de certaines difficultés
d'aménagement du courrier à travers le
monde
il est essentiel que les français de
l'étranger puissent connaître leurs
droits et mesuré incidence sur leur
future pension de certains choix de
carrière
car la plupart d'entre eux ont un
parcours professionnel assez complexes
et sont souvent affiliés à plusieurs
régimes de retraite et un moment 242
rectifié bis madame panis
cet amendement a pour objet de donner
une traduction législative aux
recommandations c'était 8 adoptée par la
délégation aux droits des femmes
celle ci souhaite tout d'abord que soit
renforcé les outils d'information
permettant d'éclairer les conséquences
en matière de retraite des choix
professionnels notamment en cas
d'expatriation
la délégation a ensuite insisté sur la
nécessité d'inciter les personnes
travaillant à temps partiel et leurs
employeurs à recourir aux possibilités
offertes par le droit en vigueur de
surcotiser elle préconise enfin de
rendre obligatoire en cas de divorce
l'élaboration d'un relevé comparatif
précis des droits à la retraite acquis
par les deux conjoints pendant leur vie
commune
en effet l'article 270 du code civil
indique que le divorce met fin aux
droits devoirs de secours entre époux et
prévoit en contrepartie que l'un d'entre
eux peut être tenu de verser à l'autre
une prestation compensatoire
l'autre article 271 du même code fait
figurer parmi les critères permettant au
juge de fixer montant de la prestation
compensatoire la situation respectifs
des époux en matière de pensions de
retraite
l'amendement vise à permettre d'apporter
au juge du divorce les éléments précis
lui permettant de prendre une décision
objective et équitable
les amendements identiques qui est il
est présenté pour le socialiste par son
président michel andré
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est en
effet la band bank qui vient de la
recommandation d'une des recommandations
qui figurent en 7 et 8 de notre
délégation est donc nous présentons cet
amendement
pour souligner la nécessité d'informer
de renforcer ces informations ces outils
qui permettent d'éclairer les
conséquences en matière de retraite des
choix professionnels
en cas d'expatriation mais également
lorsque l'un couple divorce dès lors que
l'un des deux n'a pas eu de revenus donc
de cotisation direct pendant la vie
commune et nous incitons fortement les
personnes qui travaillent à temps
partiel leurs employeurs à recourir aux
possibilités offertes par le droit en
vigueur de surcotiser je pense que ces
recommandations
voilà nous reprenons l'antenne donc
puisque il est 18 heures et il est
l'heure de preuve par trois notre invité
cette semaine gérard longuet le
président du groupe ump au sénat
gérard longuet le président du groupe
ump au sénat invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir bonsoir parcours en trois étapes
donc vous attend au cours de cette
émission gérard longuet à la toute fin
d'émission
votre liberté de ton entre audace
dérapages parfois désenchantement
politique peut-être sera soumise à
question avec perrine tarneaud de public
sénat remet ludovic vigogne de l'express
nous rejoindra dans une quinzaine de
minutes pour évoquer avec vous la
nouvelle donne politique qui se dessine
avec la dernière partie du quinquennat
et bien sûr juste après le remaniement
sur lequel vous avez quelques idées
d'abord gérard longuet l'actualité du
moment bien sûr avec la crise sociale le
blocage sur les retraites
objectivement nicolas sarkozy ne prend
il pas un risque majeur en se montrant
inflexible
le seul risque ce serait de d'accepter
un système qui conduirait très
rapidement à la faillite du système des
retraites
une retraite sur dix est payé par
l'endettement nous ne pouvons pas
accepter de passer de 30 milliards de
déficit constaté aujourd'hui par an à 45
milliards dhs en 2018
alors c'est bien sûr c'est l'avenir des
retraites étant celle ci étant seulement
là nous vient des retraites aujourd'hui
ce qui est en cause également c'est la
cohésion sociale du pays
gérard longuet non non non il y à
l'expression d'une durée d'une hostilité
à cette à ce sauvetage des retraites il
y a le refus on peut le comprendre de
travailler un peu plus longtemps passé
de 60 à 62 ans
il y a l'inquiétude sur les conséquences
du report à 67 ans du régime de décote
c'est à dire de régime par du monde à
l'époque à la partie à partir de
laquelle on touchait retraite à plein
droit
même si on n'a pas cotisé suffisamment
mais c'est un débat ce n'est certes
important mais pas l'explosion de la
société française c'est simplement un
débat c'est un débat mais vous avez vu
que les manifestations sont de plus en
plus fournie qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
marché dans la politique d' explication
la pédagogie du gouvernement les
chaussons sont en or hélas nous avons un
système qui est déficitaire parce qu'en
on a fait la retraite à 60 ans sans en
assurer le financement
michel rocard a tiré le signal d'alarmé
en 91
il y à une première réponse deux ans
après avec edouard balladur en 93
il y a une réponse en 2003 nous avons
limité la casse grâce à 93 et 2003 grâce
à 2007
mais nous n'avons pas réglé totalement
le problème à ce jour et à ce jour il y
as je me répète 30 milliards de déficit
par an c'est-à-dire une retraite sur dix
qui n'est payé que par l'endettement et
quand je vois les lycéens dans la rue sa
mince je trouve ça d'une certaine façon
assez habituel j'ai moi-même été lyciens
j'ai moi-même manifester c'était il ya
très longtemps
il ya toujours eu des manifs et des
manifestations de lycéens parce qu'on a
envie de sortie on a envie de s'exprimer
mais justement c'est à eux que qu'il
faut s'adresser leur dire allez vous
payer des retraites des déficits
accumulés par une génération qui a vécu
confortablement et qui vous renvoie la
facture alors ça c'est le travail de
pédagogie effectivement qui doit durer
dix ans d'accord mais la difficulté
france à géo lire en une seule on a une
seule formule c'est que nous avons
démarré ce travail sous l'empiré de la
nécessité
là où d'autres pays depuis dix ans ont
fait progressivement les réformes et
2003 comme 2007 ont été des réformes
utiles il l'aurait fallu sans doute
continuer en permanence mettre en
permanence le chantier de la réflexion
sur les retraites c'est peut-être là la
seule faute de cette majorité de garder
majorité précédente
c'est de nous avoir mis le sujet sur la
table en permanence et on parle du
cancer on parle de la tabagie on parle d
accidents de la route
eh bien les retraites c'est exactement
la même chose c'est tous les ans il se
passe quelque chose dans l'est des
jeunes ils sont dans la rue et vous le
savez un certain certains bien sûr mais
il était en masse dans les cortèges
et quand ils sont dans leur bulle les
cortèges aurait sans doute été moins
nombreux que le 23 septembre
mais avec eux la situation devient
incontrôlable
c'est ce que dit dominique de villepin
qui pointe un risque majeur
2002 vite est un spécialiste des
situations incontrôlables et nous
l'avons sauvé d'une aventure inutiles
qui était le cpe je crois donc qu'il est
en effet il a les références solides
oui on a matière et quand ils vivraient
quand il dit nous sommes entrés dans une
période dans une zone restait différence
fondamentale c'est que nous avons
aujourd'hui l'obligation absolue
d'assurer le sauvetage financier du
régime tel qu'il fonctionne aujourd'hui
et si nous ne faisons pas immédiatement
ceux qui prêtent de l'argent la france
en tirerons les conséquences
la france ne serait plus un pays
crédible et toute l'économie française
et tout le système social français en
subirait immédiatement les conséquences
et la raison pour laquelle sur l'
équilibre global
le président ne peut rien faire en
revanche en revanche le débat permanent
sur l'adaptation des retraites
il est ouvert par cette loi même pas ce
que nous prévoyons à la fois le rendez
vous de 2014 et nous prévoyons ce comité
de pilotage qui sera l'outil permanent
de réflexion sur les routes mais là le
débat qui nous intéresse c'est celui qui
se poursuivent d'ailleurs ces nouveautés
la loi si keira d'aéropro delà de
vendredi sans doute en tout état de
cause en 2 1 pour un vote à quelle date
selon vous je vais vous dire quand
chacun se sera exprimée et dans le
respect du règlement du sénat
voilà pour l'opposition un qui fait feu
de tout bois en ce moment contre la
réforme mondiale d'arguments une absence
totale de financement je tiens d'emblée
d'ailleurs moi au fond je suis très
contente le débat au sénat se poursuivre
parce que c'est l'occasion d'apporter la
démonstration que le parti socialiste ne
propose rien bon rien d'autre que le
déficit et la dette donc le débat il se
poursuit au sénat est ce que vous
attendez à ce que vous demandez je ne
sais pas un signe à l'elysée je tiens un
nouvel amendement un nouveau geste comme
ça c'est produit l'autre jour j'attends
les femmes rien du tout j'attends du
parti socialiste qui nous explique
comment hicham el al a fait l'elysée
l'elysée qui donne le feu vert pour les
amendements du président de la
république non c'est pas tout à fait
comme ça le sénat a proposé des
amendements il se trouve que healy à
l'article 40 dans la constitution
et cet article 40 bloquer ces
amendements nous avons obtenu la levée
de l'article 40 moi j'attendais
socialiste puisqu'il parle longtemps
l'hémicycle qu'ils nous apportent leurs
propositions ils ne le font jamais ils
sont d'ailleurs divisée entre vous le
savez puisque mana
mme aubry dit exactement le contraire de
benoît hamon fabien en tous les cas vous
n'attendez rien de l'elysée vous estimez
vous répéter aujourd'hui que l'extrême
limite a été atteinte je pense qu'il
faut sauver immédiatement ce régime de
la faillite
on peut s'interroger sur la suite des
opérations pour nicolas sarkozy c'est le
texte sera voté
1 est ce que ce sera véritablement être
votée il sera voté est ce que ce sera
forcément une victoire politique pour
nicolas sarkozy c'est parce que cherche
la majorité dans cette affaire il s'est
sans doute parce que cherche le
président la république nous cherchons
nous à sauver un système qui est
virtuellement en faillite depuis cinq
ans mais si on se place sur le terrain
politique
certains politiques nicolas sarkozy
apporte la démonstration qu'il est un
homme d'action et un homme de la
responsabilité je crois que c'était un
bon investissement vis-à-vis de
l'opinion française l'action et la
responsabilité
là où d'autres ont croisé les bras et
envoyer la facture à la génération
suivante on sait que l'opinion retiendra
qu'il aura su tenir en tous les cas ceux
qui le soutiennent dont je fais partie
et qui ont constitué une majorité sera
se retrouvent dans leur président de la
république les raisons pour lesquelles
ils ont choisi pour faire bouger la
france vous ne craignez pas que ça lui
revient comme un boomerang en 2012
70% des français soutiennent les
syndicats suis je suis complètement
d'accord avec vous sur la situation de
ce jour et à cet instant
mais l'élection présidentielle ont
choisi un candidat contre un autre
projet et nous aurions la curiosité de
connaître cet autre projet que les
français n'acceptent pas avec
enthousiasme wall premier de travailler
plus longtemps
attendez c'est pas travailler plus
longtemps n'est pas une perspective
nécessairement radieuse dans mon cas je
suis enchanté de mon travail mais je
suis un cas particulier pour mieux le
reconnaître en revanche que les français
ne l'acceptent pas je le conçois mais
lorsqu'il faudra confronter deux
attitudes deux sens des responsabilités
et deux types de solutions
il a des gens qui font le travail et qui
sauve le régime des retraites
ceux qui ne font rien et qui n'ont rien
fait dans le passé mais là les syndicats
parlons encore un peu d'eux gérard
longuet
oui et e on avait l'idée de la réforme
un ils veulent simplement des
aménagements distillats est-ce qu'on
peut les laisser bredouille
non non non je crois que ce que la loi
met en place et c'est très important on
va en parler d'ailleurs dans les jours
qui viennent dans le sait et on en parle
actuellement sur le comité de pilotage
des retraites c'est un suivi permanent
de la situation qui associe les
employeurs et les salariés avec les
pouvoirs publics et nous allons avoir
enfin en france pas simplement le comité
d'orientation des retraites qui a été
mis en place par jospin qui est
intéressant c'est un bon héritage c'est
le sol d'ailleurs mais un comité de
pilotage on prend des décisions on
propose des solutions pour qu aucun
gouvernement aucun ministre en charge
puisse s'endormir puisse esquiver
puissent reporter trop longtemps esquivé
reporter trop longtemps on s'est endormi
c'est ce gouvernement et ce président
qui vont travail c'est pas drôle ça n'a
pas ce n'est pas confortable vous déjà
là ce soir là il vous salue et déjà la
victoire politique de nicolas sarkozy ya
gérard longuet je pense qu'il est dans
son personnage d'un homme de
responsabilité et d'actions vous avez
noté peut-être comme tous les
observateurs
chez les manifestants chez les grévistes
l'expression d'une critique plus large
que celle sur sur les retraites les gens
expriment un sentiment d'injustice est
ce que vous le ressentez dans le pays
si vous voulez la france est un pays où
l'herbe est toujours plus verte dans le
champ du voisin et quand on regarde
l'assiette on considère que le voisin
est mieux servie aussi durement et
dresse ce qui est vrai c'est que la
france est confrontée une inquiétude
d'ensemble et assez curieusement quand
vous posez la question aux français ils
sont inquiets pour leur pays dans le
dans l'ensemble et à titre personnel
ils considèrent que leur situation n'est
pas si mauvaise que cela et il ya une
raison à cela c'est que malgré la crise
économique le pouvoir d'achat a continué
de grimper parce que nous avons mieux
étaler les difficultés économiques de
l'automne 2008 que d'autres pays donc
les gens individuellement se disent bon
allez ça va de ce solide collectivement
collectivement sentiment que nicolas
sarkozy porte une part de responsabilité
une part personnelle je ne le pense pas
je pense en revanche que nous sommes
dans une société de transparence absolue
ce qui est bon et qu'on découvre des
choses qui nous étonne on a découvert
des choses qui nous étonner moi j'ai
découvert que la fortune de madame
bettencourt était considérable ce que je
savais il ya savoir mais que les
conséquences de cette fortune
considérable était hors du commun
beaucoup de mes compatriotes ont le même
sentiment existe mais quel est ce pays
où les patrons du cac 40 qui le sont